today we're going to be speaking with
damon sentola who's a professor of
communication
sociology and engineering at the
university of pennsylvania also
author of the book change how to make
big things happen
damon i have to ask you is trump right
that at u-pen
they just can't stop talking about him
is that really what everybody's fixated
on there that he went
to u-pen well like most of the things
donald trump says
it you know has very little bearing on
the truth
there are very few conversations about
him most of what we talk about is how to
fix the policies that
right in place well i i want to to
really dive into the meat of this book
because i find the topic very
interesting which is what
what works to achieve social change and
what does not work and we sort of have a
bit of an example from the last year
when it comes to influencers and
vaccination there was the idea
relatively early
that getting so-called influencers
to just show themselves being vaccinated
or say it's a good idea to get
vaccinated that through their status
alone
this would convince lots of people to
get vaccinated
good strategy bad strategy based on your
research
yeah i mean the background here is that
the notion of influencers or
highly connected people as the key to
social change
um really dates back to the 1940s um
there's a there's sort of
nearly a century of research on this um
and the way that we think about it is
that people who are
really disproportionately connected and
so obviously most of us know things on
social media like like kim kardashian
characters right who are
massively connected and i think that we
have this intuition that comes from
marketing
um that companies figured out very early
on which is that someone who's so
massively connected could be really
effective for
um spreading things like new brands of
coconut water
or new teeth whitening creams right um
and
then there was this sort of
generalization and there were a series
of uh popular books written
around 2000 that kind of said well look
if
virus is spread this way and information
spreads this way
it seems like everything should spread
this way right every kind of initiative
every kind of campaign
every political movement or social
change effort should
try to make use of influencers um and
there's something really appealing about
that
which is that you know it kind of solves
a very hard problem
very hard problem is how do you get lots
of people to change their
beliefs or their behavior um vaccination
is one where
there's obviously a lot of hesitancy a
lot of uncertainty
you know reasons why people would resist
it and so if we could just find the key
people to initiate a change process
you know we would have a lot of very
hard problems solved very quickly
right um the problem with that view is
that it turns out
that the logic of disease spreading the
logic of information spreading
doesn't generalize to contagious
behaviors
that really are disruptive or that go
against the existing social norms that
challenge the way that we're thinking
and acting and require
additional more additional effort or
additional cost
and that's really the crux of my work is
showing that
the core intuition about influencers
really
only works for simple things
and you know the idea of the influencer
has come from epidemiology it's come
from the idea of like a super spreader
someone who gets sick they talk to a lot
of people
then a lot of people get sick um
so interestingly i mean i like the
example of you talked about coconut
water
it sounds like part of this is coconut
water is not something
that too many people that i know at
least feel very strongly about
they may not feel very strongly one way
or the other
and that's very different than something
like for example vaccine hesitancy and
so
what might work with something
relatively innocuous like coconut water
would not necessarily work with
something like vaccination
yeah and the core scientific distinction
here is between what's called simple
contagion and complex contagion
um and this is the big breakthrough
right so the science of contagion
20 years ago looked very different than
us today we've had a lot of new methods
but also lots of new theoretical
breakthroughs and that's kind of what
this
this book is about and what these
insights are about is that when we look
at the spread of simple contagions
which basically means information and
disease
it tends to be the case that all you
need is exposure to
one infected or activated person to
transmit it
right someone tells you a new piece of
information you don't really look around
to say how many other people knew this
piece of information
you say oh lucky me i found this out
first and then you can repeat it there's
actually a certain cachet then to the
novelty
information the same is true with the
covet 19 virus
if no one you know is sick it doesn't
really matter all you need is contact
with one sick person
to transmit the disease right right so
if you have an influence or is highly
connected they can spread to a lot of
people
the point you're making is that look
there's lots of behaviors that aren't
like that that just because we come into
contact with them
doesn't mean we adopt them in fact we
look really carefully at who that person
is maybe that person is different from
us you know we belong to one political
party they belong to a different one
we have you know we have one group of
social friends they have very different
friends
and as a result of those differences and
the sort of social factors that we
really perceive without even thinking
about it
we evaluate their behavior maybe reject
it and say oh that's kind of deviant or
i disagree with that the people in my
social group
aren't doing that and so mere exposure
isn't enough for transmission
it actually seems like there's some
research including from the field of
behavioral economics and also social
psychology that
certain types of uh beliefs that are
maybe in certain buckets
that might include religious beliefs
political beliefs etc
sometimes regularly coming into contact
with with a different
perspective will make you kind of plant
your feet
where you are if you identify that those
with a different view are from an
out group that is not your group yeah
and that's there's it even gets worse
it's not just planning your feet it's
actually you retreat back into your
kind of double down on your position
there's tech turn to term biased
assimilation just means
we assimilate new information in kind of
a biased way where the bias of our group
helps us determine what we believe and
we can actually
become even more entrenched in our
beliefs as a result of confronting
conflicting ideas but the punchline here
is this
this discovery of complex contagion that
there's this whole
class of things that we deeply care
about right everything from disruptive
products to new political initiatives to
initiatives for vaccination are
difficult to adopt and they spread
through networks in a different way
and it means that all of our classic um
theories intuitions and strategies from
epidemiology and informational marketing
not only don't work but they can like
backfire
um in in sort of the way you described
right they can backfire in the sense
that they can
make people uh more entrenched in a
position as opposed to helping loosen
their biases or weaken their biases but
also there's
lots of really sort of famous cases of
using influencers to advertise a product
and making the product
less appealing because of the way that
the influencers were so different from
everybody else
what are some examples of that the most
conspicuous one is that
is google plus and google um glass right
so a lot of us remember google glass
and google used the kind of influencer
strategy they got high profile
you know wealthy techy people in the san
francisco bay area you know cutting edge
people who are on the sort of forefront
of socio-technical sophistication
to start wearing glass and the idea was
this was supposed to create aspiration
we're all supposed to want to be like
the influencer which is the influencer
model right
um and they go out to you know
restaurants and coffee shops and they
said
i'm wearing their fancy eyewear so
everyone knows it's there right so lots
of exposure
what wound up happening was this
tremendous cultural backlash
um and everyone remembers that the term
was sort of invented by people who
encountered this
the term glass hole right for someone
who would actually wear it and that was
to distinguish people who were
part of that sort of influencer cutting
edge from the rest of us
and that was the sort of the crux of
their failures they didn't take into
account that most people
have social norms that would cause them
to reject this idea
norms about surveillance and public
norms about like just
decorum and social interactions the idea
that you'd be browsing the web while
talking to someone
right people were genuinely offended by
this technology
and so this is an instance where just
trying to kind of force it on a
population
by going through the influencers didn't
take into account the fact that the
population
is people with beliefs and norms and
they're you know if they don't like it
they don't like the way that this is
being introduced
it's actually going to be something
that's viewed in a very negative way so
this not only
caused the product line to be um stopped
entirely
but it actually hurt the reputation of
the company so that's like that's a
colossal backfire
yeah um and so it's a good example of
the sort of the issue
when it comes to change and the issue is
social norms the issue is you have to
think about
who the people are and what their
beliefs are and then how those beliefs
could change
and this is kind of a famous thing in uh
public health that public health
initiatives for decades have faced this
challenge
from trying to spread hiv prevention
technologies to now
trying to spread face masks and then
trying to spread vaccination
and most of the initial cases were you
know in sub-saharan africa and we had a
lot of data about
failures of massive efforts by the the
cdc and the nih to um change people's
behavior about hiv prevention
and their kind of hair pulling
experiences of realizing just
how bad their um
messaging strategies based on
influencers and based on stickiness and
based on viral messaging
how badly it backfired where no one
would actually
wind up using a technology that was free
easy to use and available like all the
things that are supposed to make us
wanted
yeah i remember some examples from the
2014 ebola situation
where uh western doctors were sent
into the the most at-risk and affected
countries
to talk about how this spreads and it
was just completely rejected because
they were the wrong messengers it didn't
matter what they were going to say they
were just not the right messengers for
that community
right it was it was ultimately ebola was
viewed as a
white disease because you had so many
white physicians
in these situations giving advice to
um to locals that really contradicted
social local religious norms like the
there is one in particular
like what's called standing near the ill
which is exactly what it sounds like you
actually
physically locate yourself and you're a
sick person and it's it's kind of a
spiritual commitment to them
but of course ebola is insanely
contagious
and so what they wanted to do is to
separate people from people who had like
open wounds and
and um were you know highly infectious
and so
uh the that was viewed as a kind of uh
cultural profanity
and and it sort of fell along race lines
and along culture lines
and that again created a kind of
distance you know that physicians were
this authority figure telling people
what to do
and populations resisted and to bring it
back to the point of you know what
complex contagions mean for us now
this is exactly what's happening with uh
vaccination
right right we're getting a lot of
medical experts the kind of authority
figures you know high profile people
telling people what to do and you're
getting populations kind of galvanizing
you know experiencing solidarity
around their vaccination and resistance
um
and so the whole strategy in the book
which the book was published before all
this happened right but it actually
is completely relevant to these
challenges because the whole strategy in
the book is about
when influencers fail how to engage
social networks in a way that can shift
social norms and make people more
receptive to new ideas
and so there's the story after story i
talk about black lives matter i talk
about
the civil rights movement i talk about
the berlin wall protests all these
different
sort of examples of how these social
change initiatives succeeded
actually there are technology examples
like facebook and twitter but
the punch line is that the key to social
change is
kind of the last place you would think
to look it's actually out in the sort of
margins
of the social network it's sort of the
outer edges the people who are regular
folks
and what we're looking for here isn't
special people which has been the model
for a very long time
influencers are somehow different from
the rest of us and that's what makes
them the key
change what we're actually looking for
are these special locations
in the network these sort of patterns in
the geometry of our social connectedness
and when we find those which are
actually fairly easy to find
we can actually identify locations where
it's fairly um
easy and uh practical to initiate a kind
of a critical mass dynamic where we kind
of grow support for a new movement that
might challenge what people believe but
because
there's reinforcement among friends of
friends and because it's sort of
uh in a locally clustered group they can
sort of
shift away from whatever the status quo
is and then once that critical mass
takes hold basically then you get a
cascade process where it kind of flows
through the rest of the network
and once a critical mass becomes large
enough this is where we see tipping
points happen
right and this is kind of what we saw
with black lives matter black lives
matter was this marginal fringe movement
that took hold
just regular people in communities and
then once it got large enough
you saw you know white suburban
housewives marching
with you know black inner city youth for
black lives matter which is something
that no one could have anticipated
you know five years earlier right and so
it's a real change in like
who's part of this process and all of a
sudden everyone was part of this process
and that's when we see a tipping point
that's exactly what we see
yeah anecdotally we've we've seen that
even just
like with the growth of you take any one
of our platforms like youtube where
there seems to be this geometric s-curve
that happens where initially
the amount of work required for a little
bit of growth is huge like our first
thousand subscribers our first ten
thousand subscribers
you then get enough critical mass where
maybe you get a tipping point where you
quickly get to
you know a hundred or two hundred
thousand and then there's a period where
it slows down again and then you get
sort of to the next tipping point
is that typical of the types of
movements you study as well
yeah it's typical of almost every
large-scale growth curve
um this was in the back in the 60s 1969
1970 there's this famous thing was
called the bass curve
and this was he was just describing like
consumer electronics durable goods
like refrigerators um or you know like
televisions and like what those growth
curves look like
um but what wasn't explained was the
social mechanics that
allowed that growth curve to happen and
most importantly that help that elbow in
the curve where you go from
slow glow growth into that kind of like
rapidly accelerating like exponential
growth you know week after week what's
happening at that elbow
and that was just unexplained it was
like well it took off
but like okay so what what is that and
there are a lot of things that start to
grow slowly
and then peter out so what's the
difference between those two things and
that's where my book sort of answers
that question
says well plenty of things start to grow
but they never get into the networks in
the right way and so they kind of peter
out
but if you get into networks in the
right way when you start to grow
you actually build oh that was one of my
mics you actually build
an earphone that uh yeah i just said you
build an earphone you can take that out
you actually you actually build a um
a kind of contagion process built
within the infrastructure of the social
network right
that then basically forms the basis of
the critical mass and that is the
difference between the cases where you
get that elbow up and the pace
in the cases where you just kind of
peter out um and that's kind of the
powerful lesson is that
that's something we can control we can
do experiments on and more importantly
we can develop policy around
that makes a ton of sense and uh we've
been we've been speaking about
much of what is in damon centaula's book
change
how to make big things happen uh he
is a professor in a number of
disciplines at the university of
pennsylvania
damon so great speaking to you today
absolutely thank you